have recovered from the coronavirus  hospitals are hoping that you can help  them fight the pandemic as well  here in the valley health officials are  asking survivors of the coronavirus to  donate their blood and convalescent  plasma  now treating people with that material  can help save the lives of some of the  sickest covid19 patients and right now  there is a plasma shortage giving  plasma isn't dangerous it's a safe it  essentially is a blood donation and this  is a way you can really help patients  and protect and potentially even save  someone's life  if you can help call 1-800 red cross you  can book an appointment to donate  there are also several other facilities  across the valley that will also  take your blood and plasma to help other  people fight in the coronavirus